We get it — sometimes, kid-friendly films
are just plain unbearable for adults.
Filmmakers understand this too, and often
try to add things that make being trapped
in a theater with a hundred sniffling kids
more tolerable.
Occasionally, however, they go a little too
far.
Here are a few adult jokes we can't believe
they allowed in kids movies.
Inside Out
Pixar's 2015 animated feature Inside Out was
obviously kid-friendly, being Pixar and all.
There was, however, one joke that pushed the
envelope just a bit.
"What was that?
Was it a bear, it's a bear?"
"There are no bears in San Francisco."
"I saw a really hairy guy, he looked like
a bear."
If you've ever taken a stroll through the
Castro District in San Francisco, you probably
know exactly what Anger is talking about.
"Everybody bottoms up."
"Bottoms up"
Aladdin and The King of Thieves
In the third installment of Disney's Aladdin
franchise, our hero finally gets the girl.
Since this was a direct-to-video production,
Robin Williams, who returned as the hilarious
Genie, made a bawdy joke that maybe shouldn't
have made it past the editors.
"I thought the earth wasn't suppose to move
until the honeymoon."
Get it?
Yeah...you get it.
And of course, this wouldn't be the first
time Disney got a little frisky.
Mrs. Doubtfire
Robin Williams was given free rein when it
came to his improvizations in Mrs. Doubtfire,
with the understanding that the final film
would be cut to a still-family friendly, if
a little cheeky, PG-13 rating.
Williams got so risqué with his off-the-wall
freestyling that there's another unseen version
of the movie which is rated NC-17.
We're not sure how much more suggestive it
can get than this, however.
"A bit of a going down payment, hm?"
"Excuse me?"
"You know dear, sink the sub, hide the weasel,
pop the porpoise, bit of the old humpty dumpty,
little jack horny, the horizontal mumbo, hm."
"Mrs. Doubtfire"
"The bone dancer, rumpleforskin, baloney bop,
bit of the old cunulinquistics, hm."
"Mrs. Doubtfire, please."
Scooby-Doo
In the live-action adaptation of Scooby-Doo,
the gang takes a flight to Spooky Island.
Along the way, Shaggy finds himself unexpectedly
seated next to a blonde bombshell on the airplane,
who introduces herself.
"I'm Marry Jane."
"Like that is my favorite name."
"Really"
"Yeah"
Thanks, Warner Brothers, for finally confirming
what fans have suspected all along.
Now we know why Shaggy's always got the munchies…
"Like wow, my favorite.
A double triple decker sardine and marshmallow
fudge sandwich."
The Road to El Dorado
In this DreamWorks animated adventure, our
hero Tulio falls in love with the lovely Chel,
and the pair spend some quality time together.
But in one particular scene, the film goes
from romantic to downright explicit.
"Woah,"
"My lords, hello"
"The high priest"
"Oww"
Sure does look like the animators were going
for something a little more serious than kissing.
Muppet Treasure Island
It's in Muppet Treasure Island that we learn
Kermit the Frog's sometime-girlfriend, Miss
Piggy, or Benjamina Gunn in the context of
this film, has been seeing some other guys,
like Long John Silver.
Well, more than seeing.
"This seems to be your day for renewing old
acquaintances."
"Well, hello Loooong John."
"Oh no, him too."
Thanks for that, Muppets.
"Dad, what's a muppet?"
"Well, it's not quite a mop, it's not quite
a puppet but man, he he he he.
So to answer your question, I don't know."
The Brave Little Toaster to the Rescue
The writers behind The Brave Little Toaster
to the Rescue didn't even bother to hide this
one, which comes complete with soft-jazz bedroom
music.
"Wow"
"What's happening"
"Frikenstin is searching through all my files.
Searching through regions here to for only
dreamed of by man.
Wooo, that feels sorta good."
"What does"
"My memory banks are being stroked and by
an expert.
I feel something, something happening inside
of me and I can't keep it to myself any longer."
Nope, your eyes and ears aren't fooling you.
That was the grossest thing you've seen a
computer do all day.
And considering what most computers are used
for these days, that's really saying something.
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
During one notable scene in the 2014 Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles reboot, the huge, heroic
reptiles are introduced to reporter April
O'Neil.
As Raphael tries to get her to hand over the
photo she just snapped, we can hear this sleazy
remark….
"Oh, she's so hot I can feel my shell tightening."
"We can hear you."
We can hear him too.
Time to wash our ears til they bleed!
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know your
favorite adult jokes in kids movies...